I've also tattooed buttholes and put
flames on them I've done all kinds of
interesting things in my career my name
is Ralph Rosa my name is Jason Ackerman
my name is Rafael Marte and I'm a tattoo
artist professional tattoo artist I am a
professional tattoo artist I got my
first tattoo at the age of 17 when I was
18 years old
at 18 and it was a design that I had
made myself when I got to the tattoo
shop and it was squid octopus I picked
it off the wall what made me want to get
that first tattoo I walked into a shop
saw it on the wall pointed at it and
said hey I want that so the weirdest
tattoo I've ever done on someone was
this woman came in and she wanted to get
chocolate-covered strawberries and it
was dripping chocolate and it was all
over her vagina the weird thing about
that was that she brought her 18 year
old daughter and she was like 45 years
old and she bought her daughter as moral
support I'd have to say the most awkward
for me was tattooing a gentleman's [ __ ]
I turned it literally the entire thing
from tip to balls into a snake it was
surreal
I absolutely hate it when I'm sitting in
the shop and a client walks in and they
have no idea what they want to get they
tell us we could do whatever we want and
then we start drawing stuff up and it's
never what they want so it makes no
sense to us nobody ever really means do
what you want do what they think what
they mean is do what they want as long
as you can figure it out which is next
to impossible I need a tattoo what do
you think I should go oh by the way my
flight leaves in three hours getting a
tattoo does hurt whoever doesn't say it
doesn't hurt it's they're a little weird
but you know everyone takes pain
differently it's not terrible it's not
as bad as people think it's all about
your state of mind
honestly everybody's different like
literally like where I think the most
painful spot on the body is which would
be like ribs or lower back for me
personally I tattoo people all day
that's it like it's nothing of course
yeah who does a bull when it has a
professional I'm supposed to be
objective and not judge people however
as a human I judge everybody that walks
through the door as artists we have to
you know give them what they want I'm
just gonna give you a good piece we want
you to walk out with a great piece if
you come in with an idea you're going to
an artist that you like their style and
if you like their work then you're gonna
get something really good I think if the
tattoo is composed really well and it's
a very dynamic tattoo as an artist I
think that makes for a really great
tattoo for as far as a client goes my
end goal is to have a client leave with
a smile on their face if they're happy
and they love what I did then that's
perfect I would say before you get a
tattoo you definitely need to think
about it look for artists that you like
so that you know what style you're
looking for at this day and age if you
get a bad tattoo you kind of deserve it
it's because you didn't do the research
a lot of people get like small tattoos
to start off to feel the pain and all
that I always say don't do that
if you want something big get it big and
don't be stickler about money we put
years into our craft and we're worth
what we we ask for good tattoos aren't
cheap and cheap tattoos aren't good if
you know somebody that can do it in
their garage by all means go get it but
I'm gonna charge you a lot to fix it
[Music]